a popular website requires users to  create a password consisting only of  digits if no digit may be repeated and  each password must be at least nine  digits long how many passwords are  possible  let's solve this problem  there are 10 digits going from zero to  nine the maximum length of the password  is therefore 10 because none of the  digits can be repeated so how many  passwords are 10 digits long there are  10 factorial ways to order 10 digits we  also know the minimum length of the  password is 9 digits and once again we  cannot repeat digits so first we want to  know the number of ways to choose nine  digits from 10 digits that is 10c9 which  is equal to 10. then we can arrange  these nine digits in nine factorial ways  multiplying these together gives 10  multiplied by 9 factorial which is equal  to 10 factorial so the total number of  passwords is equal to 10 factorial plus  10 factorial which is equal to 2  multiplied by 10 factorial and the  correct answer choice is B